[MUSIC]
I fell hopelessly in love 15 years ago.
I was only 16 years old,
a junior in high school.
But Stacey Carson was a mature
sophisticated 18 year old.
And as far as I could tell,
she was absolutely perfect.
Drop dead gorgeous,
incredibly kind, a ton of fun to
hang out with, and she had a way of
making everyone she talk to feel that they
were the most special person in the world.
She had my heart.
When the opportunity came to ask her out,
I seized the moment,
a friend called one night to tell me that
she had just split with her boyfriend.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, I put on my oversized green suit
and tie and
I spit on way too much cologne.
I grab the rose on my mom's flower vase.
And I jumped into my brother's
red 1987 Chevrolet Camaro and
I sped down to the high school two blocks
away, arriving just in time to see Stacy
exiting the school after finishing
her after school dance rehearsals.
I put my foot to the gas and
I sped across the parking lot and
I came to a screeching
halt in front of Stacy.
No doubt she was terrified.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I swung open that big heavy door
>> And jumped and slid across the hood and
I extended the rose.
[LAUGH] And then, without even thinking,
the words that came out of my
mouth were will you marry me.
[LAUGH]
I was shocked,
because this is not what I wanted to say.
[LAUGH] I was even more surprised
when she actually said yes.
[LAUGH] Because that's who she was.
And then she laughed and
I laughed, we laughed together for
a while and then I asked her to attend the
Winter Ball with me, to which she obliged.
I spent the next two weeks doing
everything I could to make sure I would be
the perfect date for her,
including taking dance lessons.
because she loved dancing and
I was terrible at it.
But that wasn't going to stop me.
And the night of the dance came and
it was magical.
We danced the night away.
I was falling in love.
Five years later, I asked
Stacy Carson that same big question.
This time, on purpose.
[LAUGH] And
she said this time,without laughing Yes.
And on August 19,
2006 at 1:00 PM we were married.
It was another magical moment.
We were in love.
Five years passed approaching
our 5th wedding anniversary.
And a lot had changed.
I was working 80+ hours a week for
a crazy consulting firm and
my wife was working even harder to take
care of our six month old baby boy Jake.
We were both completely exhausted.
I came home one night after
a regular day in the office,
2 AM, and I walked in to find my poor
wife sitting on the kitchen floor.
With tears streaming down
her mascara stained face.
She looked at me, she said, why aren't
you here for me when I need you?
And then, without even thinking,
the words that came out of my mouth were,
I'm doing the best that I can for this
family, why aren't you more appreciative?
And I went to bed that night ashamed and
asking myself the question,
what happened to our hopeless love?
Is this a sign that it's not meant to be?
I found the answers to these
questions in the work of Dr.
Jennifer Finlayson-Fife, a marriage and
family counselor from the University
of Boston, from Boston University.
In her work she teaches that
love goes through three phases.
Phase 1, love without knowledge.
This is the blissfully and
well phase that we all enjoy when
we're first falling in love.
This is the phase when your
partner is always on your mind and
you're willing to do anything for
her or him.
Including taking dance lessons.
In this phase,
your brain is actually addicted to love.
Your brain enjoys heightened
levels of neurotransmitters,
adrenaline, dopamine, and serotonin,
all of which form this crazy cocktail
of love that leaves you feeling joy,
vulnerability and
complete love, or so it seems.
But this phase will not last forever,
because eventually that heightened level
of euphoria goes away and you enter
phase two, knowledge without love.
This is the might as
well be room mates phase.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In this phase, reality sets in, and
you start to notice the small things, and
the big things about your partner, that
are failing to meet your expectations,
and you stop trying to impress.
This is the phase you
realize that love is hard.
This is where I was on that
fateful night at 2 AM.
But the beautiful thing is that
love can be better than that.
And those who choose to leave that
phase will enter phase three,
knowledge with love.
In this phase you still have
a full appreciation for
your partner's weaknesses and faults.
You still know exactly how
your relationship is failing
to meet your needs, but
you choose not to dwell on them.
Instead, you choose to focus
on improving yourself for
your partner because love is worth it.
And when the two partners equally
commit to working on self improvement,
they can grow in to phase three.
And at that point you can really enjoy
the fruits of long lasting love and
companionship.
Stacy and
I have been married ten years this August.
And in a few days we welcome our
third child into our family.
I love her.
And we are not always in phase three.
But we know how to get there.
And we know that it's worth it.
And we're both committed to working
toward it every single day.
So I want to leave you with a few
tips that I've learned through my ten
years of marriage.
[LAUGH] Which doesn't make me an expert,
but also not a novice.
[LAUGH] I like to consider
myself an apprentice of love.
[LAUGH]
Tip number one, learn how to love.
Dr. Gary Chapman in his
New York Times bestselling book,
The Five Love Languages teaches us that
people feel loved in different ways.
Your love language may be physical touch.
Whereas yours maybe words of affirmation.
This distinction does not matter in
phase one but it does in phase two.
I know that Stacy is
particularly happy and
feeling love when I speak a specific
dialect of physical touch.
The daily foot massage.
I must have been high on dopamine
the day I committed to that one.
Advice number two Learn how to fight.
Dr. John Gottman is the master at this.
In his 30 plus year longitudinal study,
he came to two, I think,
relevant conclusions.
One, greater than 60% of relationship
conflict is unresolvable.
It's simply a difference of opinions.
And number two,
the marital masters learned to
fight with a smile on their face.
I know this is easy to say, and
I know it's a lot harder to do, trust me.
But I also know that it's worth it.
So next time you're in a fight,
don't try to be right.
Try to understand your
partner's point of view.
Try to argue with compassion.
Finally, advice number three,
learn how to forgive.
Unfortunately, I have seen how
an unwillingness to forgive
can tear apart families.
The longer you're with someone the more
likely it is that feelings will be hurt.
That's just the reality of love.
And if we let that hurt
feelings linger for too long,
it will poison your ability to live every
day expressing those love languages,
to live every day arguing with compassion,
that prevents you in enjoying the true
joys of long lasting relationships
that I enjoy everyday with Stacy.
So that's it, no big secret.
That's what works for me.
So next time you find yourself in a long
term relationship and things get rocky,
because trust me they will,
rather than asking is this meant to be,
first try asking what more can I do and
then get to work because it's hard.
But I can tell you that it's worth it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]